oh they can't exclusive studio summer
Vegas is finest I got interstate fats I
got the homie trade for he's and of
course marry right right now man I got
my dude radio remote so that's what we
gonna do we're gonna just play some
instrumentals and we're gonna let these
dudes do what they do best and that's
spit fire like dylon son all right let's
do this man radio remote you're ready to
dial on in the building
here we go Radio one year anniversary
radio look [__] I'm hungry it's time for
some action would you be Michael Jordan
and I guess some Phil Jackson in 96
balls or the 99 late cuz I got 99
problems and 99 haters on nothing guys
in the sanctuary don't approach my back
baby
I can handle dad feeling like I'm Frank
boy Jesus cross running to the end zone
I wear the city on my shoulder pads but
[__] ball mess around to be your life
for your mom's rings delay my mom's
rings the fighter plane without a
lighter baby without a diaper I'm
[__] on you why you faked my car
fight look or the transit hate mail kept
running all these tracks and I swear on
my eighth mile and she's wearing it
changes mouth trumpets in my
[__] stomach you ass war and
they get eight Miles Davis hot boxing in
avis I'm barely past the state line I
still see Vegas blind titty haters
shades on my face and I'm looking past
these [__] but I still see the paper
if a [__] I was show love but love is
overrated
and what's love and love turn nature cuz
you out shining out Ronnie's think it's
worse than females hate me now the money
spin like Sprewell's
[__] trying press females choke him
out and change my rap name to Sprewell
[__] and they thought that boy was
conscious I was until I met God he told
me children on
now the angel of death gave birth to a
monster and everybody knows I'm their
[__] monster huh yeah we're too
easy
they say that [__] go hard but he make
you look easy [__] fats pass me a
please say that maybe go hard but he
make you look yeah please yo somebody
cut it in the radio man doing what he
does miss are good that was a beautiful
day schools are next to flow deep guys
on top yeah mariya right Vegas yeah yeah
million dollar BOCES blood up a king I'm
rich off these [__] let's go I
gotta get high yeah yeah million dollar
roses blood of a king I'm Rick's off
these peasants making struggle for the
drain my squad she's hungry for the ring
like his sword for their head you can't
dogs the guillotine I'm on fire a
genocide Malati or the Nazis miss Barack
to Allah I said its highest IV Max and
Abdullah be watching a dog haunted by
Jews down a million times in the gas
chamber I let the past pay Chuck say
clerks with your makeup and real Jesus
let the Mac great yup
hey from Norfolk to Vegas to the majors
I'm so glad to sky haters if I'm going
on hiatus
just look up hi haters I'm sitting in
the skyscraper feeling like LeBrons
paper I'm the chosen one y'all know if
you know this one and I'll split the Red
Sea again as if I'm
son oh oh [__] yo yo keep going [__] it
let's go yeah yeah yo tummy at the beat
yeah yeah this is my life young hey okay
let's go
yeah listen hey hey hey hey yeah Oh
leave my last day like the rapture as
far as I was trying to grab your
diseased minds moves through the greater
good like cancer no trust for no man no
love for no [__] and no peace for the
chair with the handgun and saliva says
they come
karai the reality lungs United without
hostility rebels without the bum mass
[__] kids reclass dumb ass trash [__]
sweet mama's boy beat you back with her
snatches your young ass blaster Chang
ready for war this is for my three
hundred warriors smashing of George but
I don't care about what you say you can
run young and you can hide but you a
hand of like Osama and who say hi shot
only swear with a lot of us here got one
for no comparisons you're my soldiers I
get on rebels to get society living
without fear or just rebels without a
cause just look over to the man we're
killing the game saying you know I'll be
killing it millions on give a [__]
I'm just here chillin in skyscraper
chilling in the oh let's go
yo yo homie train trades up next there
you go yeah yeah
check yep oh it goes where the [__] is
my sanity man help me find it I think I
lost it when I started being open-minded
I like [__] that most people would find
absurd so I'm put them in the roms
murder by mere words fascinated by your
culture of the macabre
musics all I got so I gotta make it my
job so I fuse it with death sex and all
sorts of bad [__] that I don't wanna say
out loud in front of my dad [__] like
Charles in Thompson babies in
incinerators while in agley rapes their
mothers in a [__] basement hook
that's just Huey Lewis in the news it's
hip to be square now who made us cool
let me grab my raincoat cause this could
get messy my name's Paul and that's
between y'all whatever y'all do up in
that bathroom stall just make sure you
don't get blood on all the walls
change the channel if you don't like it
your flows on hold like play Texas safe
sex I explode on the track for the
excitement next morning pills turn that
plus into a - smash it on the glass
table and then ignited in the pipe and
catch a euphoric eye until you're dying
the [__] hot like Cayenne my homecoming
James's Cheyenne do you know who the
[__] I am
Apocalypse Now we're all rap for him I'm
snuffing go I'm lyrical porn [__]
murder and mayhem I put black metal
shotgun suicides on my covers and my
fans love me yeah yeah
that was the business shout-out to trade
for his manners now we got the Beast
this dude is gonna be on 106 upon Friday
what oh hi desert my man stayed up
Indian Springs do what you do fast do
what I do
let me get into my zone I'm on the radio
with my mom and they're being right my
flow deep
wait a minute trade boy he's I got a
speech come off with the heat all I do
is just combined to the beat I'm from
the east mouthpiece liquors grease I'm a
beast from up block where we holding him
things three years flat I'm back in the
thick of it anything I put my mouth on
I'm ripping it I'll do kickin it in the
booth get in it Las Vegas native colder
than an Inuit pencil whip rappers like
I'm the scorekeeper a bright soul
grabbers Spit pure ether green light
that's his own goal like a Tweaker my
music is more exclusive than your
sneakers never been stepped on this is
that piss a verse without a curse in it
give you that gift acrobatic automatic
it'll make you backflip he he's on fire
my shot can't miss that the man making
one two three four fit where is the
camera huh
better record this we measures up to me
I'm enormous when I perform Rick the
rulers couldn't be more swing really
hope that you record this imma keep it
until we sittin on the Forbes list for
now I'm on the piss poreless pockets
tapped out it ain't in my genes before
fit I'm a righteous man lucky mind
trying to find a way to help the fam hit
the studio I dropped the jewel hoping
it'd pay but the hunger in the stomach
isn't going away so many dreams should I
throw them away
plus I feel like all the good music been
going to waste it ain't what you know
it's who you know you know what they say
I know when I get on the stage i'ma blow
them away without talk about how I'm
about to blow them away just to carry it
all away I had to throw them away
brand new tracks get Randy's facts truth
your ice too
who's that dude reason you're the fast
food I'll rap whole prison yards ask
your dreams I'll trap all the decoys
last June 300 on the dash vamoose
all y'all crime fighters my line shine
like I hit him with a highlighter
prostitutes robberies white came my
style migraine feel my pain no [__]
takes no rap demo I just kill him on the
web like a black widow southeast bakers
crack central disrespecting get
stretched like a black limo it's that
simple
yo that was yo I don't even know what to
say homie I
hey yo shout-out to interstate fast that
was that was one of the most incredible
raps I've ever been in front of in my
life
man hey thank you brother hey hey you
mind kicking something else
just do one more let's do one more amen
that's no Ready Set Radio pool they
can't let's do this one two three fold
who is he go gotta flow that on
alternate GE go with the breeze Oh see
my peoples up early in the moment each
of these so I don't need no veto but
I'll eat shows if my kid goes where your
people's we'd be picking through your
peep holes with the thing bro
we about to let the heat go what you
thought it was boom I'm gonna kick the
water down like a diamond soon fools oh
yeah I'm an ignoramus
if you ain't talking money you talk in
two different language I'm out of state
you got a quarter kick up in her anus
corner kick up in her anus trying to
hide it I'm the one she can fight in his
ride in from the east side I'm gonna tie
in not fulfilling make him look silly
February 11 from about the childers
technic philly
slang going from the brain this is
nothing all I trap is the pain line for
line like your tweet habit I find the
microphone and I speak at it oh he
crashed it he smashed it bandicoot I'm
leaving with your soul and you leave do
what you have to do back in dudes I'd be
classic doing straight breaking them
smashing food and then asking dude from
Tropicana Avenue 5100 ESOP boulders
stripped where the fold is flip where
the bow just get it slum by the young
kids for a new fit when you do this you
ain't gonna do nada
split your head wide open like a pinata
you can get nada
not from me I do this for my pockets
locked up we hungry gotta eat stuck on
the top tier all these rappers think
that they top tier no I'm not here no
when I'm around come right around
I ain't bring the right around way on
the town the soil my lying down black
they don't want to see fast see that
watch me grab the feet and I get it ten
minutes
did you defendants over not speak not me
sick like a Nazi
my mental ain't right got these black
Breck was running from me it's a rolling
a dice but you was playing a game Nazi
hard rock by your Hard Rock's of a
paradise right next to the Hard Rock no
boys you need a new charger charger and
I ain't talking about the car we wild
like a dingo so they build enough fits
is trying to keep us away from they
livestock we be getting sick what would
we be sick hold on is this to be time on
I'm spitting I'm living time for me to
live man let me in the studio can I will
trade for hey Sumerian right about the
Barry the mic come with radio Rahman on
the radio write me a bootleg kids with a
kilter tonight yeah yeah hey shouts the
fats